et l'on reparle de la sphère du petit
grégory à l'occasion des obsèques
aujourd'hui de la mer de marie-ange
laroche les pousses de bernard laroche
un moment soupçonné du crime est
assassiné par son beau frère jean marie
villemin la polémique vient du fait que
l'un des avocats de la famille laroche
estime que c'est la récente libération
provisoire de jean marie villemin en
attendant son jugement qui a choqué la
mère de marie-ange laroche au point de
décéder d'une crise cardiaque à l'âge de
57 ans et le moins que l'on puisse dire
c'est que l'atmosphère était
particulièrement tendue pendant la
cérémonie des obsèques cet après midi
isabelle béchet la ville in devant
bruyère vosges dans cette vallée de la
vologne où les victimes de l'affairé
grégory ne se comptent plus le deuil
encore frappé du côté des laroche
jeanine bol est décédé voilà trois jours
à l'âge de 57 ans elle était mère de dix
enfants dont marie-ange la veuve de
bernard laroche et muriel qui avait mis
en cause son beau-frère pour toute cette
famille la vie avait basculé avec la
faire voilà trois ans vraiment entre les
os et gréements ayad la justice je veux
qu'il faut chercher la chose et qu'on
sache la vérité une vérité est acquis
c'est jean marie villemin qui a tué
bernard laroche le libérer c'était comme
tuer bernard une seconde fois pour sa
famille
après un moment de consternation moment
d'indignation au moment de colère et
après la tristesse provoqué par la mort
de madame ball mère de marie ange
laroche et grand mère de sébastien
laroche qui n'a pas supporté le choc et
qui en est morte
c'est une volonté de justice que jean
marie villemin passe aux assises mais
aussi de volonté que ce dossier soit
confié dossier d'instruction de mort de
grégory villemin le dossier
d'instruction consomma plainte contre
les gendarmes se confiait d' un
magistrat qui ne soit pas le juge simon
cas montré trop de partialité aux yeux
de la famille laroche la libération de
jean marie villemin traduit la volonté
d'étouffer la faire et non pas de
rechercher la vérité au cours jean marie
villemin assassins de bernard laroche
des loges je ne suis pas convaincu que
l'on veut vraiment trouver l'assassin de
grégory villemin
vous ne verrez de cet enterrement qu'un
cimetière vide dans sa douleur et son
indignation la famille n'a pas pu
maîtriser sa colère des menaces et des
voies de fait ont découragé les
journalistes présents dans la région